check-check you got to know your limits
cash psychologically messed up snake
bracelets treat Dairy Queen cake
trick-or-treat we've got a little
two-part question for you guys
trick-or-treat which one you want first
trick trick who's the biggest prankster
on set and has there been a joke that
went a little too far
we just got pretty packaging and a theme
well my thought we did let me just get
like five seconds ago
Frankie Potter it was a little far it
was like a little because I was like
though cameras were rolling and
something there really we were doing
intimate scene and he is pops up what
did he say he said oh it's about time
like is it a little makeout scene yeah
very stressful that's funny though you
four are the architects of this outrage
you know we received the prank questions
often but we asked it because people on
your set actually prank people I I mean
I suppose I guess KJR Charles it's more
of just scaring one another to death
consistently and halting production
holy hell retching I think all the boys
are just really bad pranking each other
and you know they don't pull like pranks
like normal like that you would think it
and I like high school pranks it's very
like they like pretend to be really
angry and getting fights and then
they're actually not it's very strange
and psychologically messed up but um I
don't know I think like Charles KJ and
Cole are all sort of weird is there a
problem guys numbre oh cool KJ is the
biggest is the biggest prankster but I
can't think of like a moment that it was
like way too much mhm
cuz the pranks are necessarily like haha
like I poured water on your head they're
not those kind of prank they're like
it's just KJ goofing around constantly
no I think we're pretty good at putting
a cap on it I think we're pretty good at
not getting in trouble I think mostly
because we're all scared
especially with the girls you got to
know your limits that's not true that's
not true
I have to start writing the stuff down
that happens so when I'm in interviews
like who pulls pranks on you I can be
like well let me check I'm not the
biggest prankster when I get on set it's
like all right let's do this yeah
screams I'm just not used to this I'm
sorry
cami trick or treat treat okay what is
something sweet that one of your
co-stars has done for you behind the
scenes oh that's a tough one
it's a good question they don't do
anything sweet for me I don't think any
of them have done anything yet that if
that meaningful that I would limit on
sit behind the scenes to be to be quite
honest if I think they're selling le
it's hard to fish I'm so bad at this
these kinds of questions you should
probably skip I'm gonna sit here for
like 30 minutes trying to think of
something yet to be I don't know if I've
done anything she like I was like grab
that I gave you your little bracelet
yesterday oh sure give me a little snake
bracelet or necklace choker necklace we
do sweet things yet she brought me
coffee this morning oh yeah we've all
ordered each other's coffees we've all
done that I don't know I think of
probably when it's our our birthdays
someone like plans are our cake
situation or someone like usually they
someone maybe Casey he tries to get me
like a Dairy Queen cake because I love
Dairy Queen
that's usually very sweet you know gifts
cash whenever they give me lots of cash
I really like that toodles
[Music]